Government regulation of land
in the western United States on balance,
doesn't protect the
environment from industry.
It protects industry
from having to compete
in the free market.
Why can't environmentalists
acquire the land
that they want to preserve?
Often, because it's illegal.
Shawn Reagan is the vice
president of research
at the Property and
Environment Research Center,
which is a leading advocacy group
in the free-market
environmentalist movement.
He says preservation groups
are often willing to compete
with industry on a level playing field.
They are looking to use markets,
to use property rights,
to use voluntary exchange,
to essentially get what they want,
which is preserving natural amenities,
conserving wildlife and open space.
So in the case of public lands,
we see groups trying to acquire
rancher's grazing permits,
we see groups trying to
buy federal energy leases
to keep the resources in the ground.
We even see groups trying
to bid for timber leases,
but to keep the trees standing
rather than harvesting them.
In many cases, though,
they've been thwarted
by rules that basically make that illegal.
Most people think of
public lands in the west
as being national parks
or wilderness areas,
but really most of the lands
in the west are managed
by other federal agencies
and they're fundamentally political lands.
Reagan says that these
lands are often leased
through public auctions,
but environmental groups that
want to pay for the right
to preserve them are frequently
excluded for participating.
Too often, natural resource
management is biased
towards resource extraction
because rules that were created
in the 19th century essentially
require rightsholders
to harvest, extract, or graze the resource
rather than to conserve it.
Because federal agencies
don't consider conservation
to be a beneficial public use,
environmental groups are locked out.
Reagan says that in a free market,
the highest bidders should win
even if their intention is
to leave the land untouched.
Our idea of a beneficial
use is much broader.
A lot of times the highest valued use
would be a community
coming together to decide
that a forest should be left
standing rather than harvested,
or conserved for some
recreational opportunity.
Reagan points to one case
in which environmentalist
successfully preserved land
in Bozeman, Montana by
outbidding the competition.
The state offered up a timber sale
on some state-owned lands, south of town,
and a community group formed
to oppose this project.
But rather than trying
to litigate or regulate,
they attempted to outbid
the timber company
instead of harvesting the trees.
And the local group raised enough money
to purchase this lease.
They outbid the timber company.
And for 25 years,
they have the right to
keep these trees standing.
And yet the Montana
Legislature's response was
to change the law to prevent
environmentalist groups
from competing against timber
companies in the future.
In the case of the Bozeman timber sale,
the community group paid more
than the logging company.
So taxpayers in Montana earn
more from this nonuse right
than they would have from a timber sale.
And I think that's an important
distinction here is that,
just because we're leaving trees standing
doesn't mean that we're
not going to generate
as much revenue.
It's, in fact, the only
way that this lease
would have moved forward,
is if the group outbid
the logging company.
The lease that the group
purchased is good for 25 years.
And so after the 25-year period,
they'd have to acquire
another similar lease
and the state would stand
to earn even more revenue
from another Conservation License.
Whereas, if the lease had
gone to the logging company,
it would take a hundred years
before that forest would regrow
to the point where it could
potentially be harvested again.
By excluding environmental
groups, Reagan says,
we get a distorted picture about the value
of our natural resources.
The point is not that
resource development is bad.
It's not that extracting
energy is fundamentally wrong
or harvesting timber
is fundamentally wrong.
We all live in a house
likely that's made of wood.
But rather, it's that
environmental values are real
and they're legitimate
and we need to find ways
to allow for those values
to be expressed through markets
and through voluntary exchange.
I think a system of non-use rights
where markets can help resolve
these competing demands
is a system that can help us
allocate resource extraction
to places where it makes the most sense
and do conservation where it
makes the most sense as well.